IT'S CLEAR THAT THE NUTTY NADLER
CIRCUS WON'T BE BETTER, IT'S
WORSE.
REACTION OF TWO OF THE STARS OF
TODAY'S HEARING, OHIO
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN AND HOUSE
JUDICIARY RANKING MEMBER, SHOULD
BE THE SENATOR ELECT OF THE
GREAT STATE OF GEORGIA IN MY
HUMBLE OPINION, DUMB DECISION BY
THE GOVERNOR OF THE STATE OF
GEORGIA, A LOT OF FRIENDS THERE,
HE DID A GREAT JOB TODAY.
RANKING MEMBER COLLINS, I WILL
THEEAR IF TO YOUR RANK HERE.
NO FACT WITNESSES.
THREE PEOPLE THAT HATE DONALD
TRUMP, THEY EXPRESSED THEIR
OPINIONS REPEATEDLY, RADICAL
VIEWPOINTS.
WHY WERE THEY EVEN THERE.
>> THEY WERE THERE BECAUSE JERRY
NADLER HAD TO FIGURE OUT
SOMETHING TO DO.
HE HAS NO PLAN.
AS I SAID TODAY, THE CLOCK AND
THE CALENDAR, NOT THE FACTS ARE
DRIVING THIS, SEAN.
AND, LOOK, WE SHOWED IT TODAY.
JIM JORDAN, JOHN RADCLIFFE,
WITHE BLEW HOLES IN IT BECAUSE
IT'S SO EASY.
WE HAVE THE FACTS ON OUR SIDE.
ALL THEY HAVE IS HATRED OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ALL THEY HAD IS NOT LIKING A MAN
WHO CAME TO OFFICE TO DO WHAT HE
SAID HE WAS GOING TO DO AND HE'S
DOING.
IF YOU HAVE FACTS AND TRUTH ON
YOUR SIDE, IT WILL WIN EVERY
TIME.
>> SEAN: YOU'RE PROBABLY GLAD
THAT CONGRESSMAN COLLINS DIDN'T
GET THE PROMOTION TO THE UPPER
CHAMBER.
>> I'M GLAD HE'S WHERE HE'S AT
AS WELL.
>> FOUR FACTS NEVER CHANGE, JIM
JORDAN.
NOT ONLY THAT, FIVE MEETINGS
AFTER THE FOUR FACTS.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY COULD DO
IT AS WELL AS YOU DO IT.
EXPLAIN?
>> YOU'RE KIND.
BUT I LOVED YOUR MONOLOGUE
BECAUSE THE DISDAIN THAT THESE
PEOPLE THAT THEY BROUGHT IN
TODAY -- THESE PROFESSORS HAVE
FOR US REGULAR AMERICANS WHO
VOTED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP, NEVER
FORGET, SEAN, 17 DAYS AGO, THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE ON A SUNDAY
SHOW CALLED THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AN IMPOSTER.
THE GUY WHO HAD 63 MILLION
PEOPLE VOTE FOR HIM, THE GUY WHO
WON BY LANDSLIDE, THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE CALLING THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AN
IMPOSTER, THAT WAS THE ATTITUDE
ON DISPLAY FROM THE THREE
WITNESSES THAT THE DEMOCRATS
CALLED IN.
THEY HAD TO CALL THEM IN.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE FOUR FACTS YOU JUST TALKED
ABOUT.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE FIVE MEETINGS WHERE ZELINSKY
MET WITH SENIOR OFFICIALS IN THE
TIME THE AID WAS PAUSE AND NOT
IN ONE OF THOSE MEETINGS DID
LINKING AID TO ANY TYPE OF
INVESTIGATION COME UP.
NOT ONCE.
THEY GOT NO CASE, NO FACTS.
THAT I HAVE TO BRING IN THE
ELITES TO LOOK DOWN THEIR NOSE
AND SAY THE THINGS THAT THE
PROFESSOR SAID TODAY ABOUT THE
FIRST FAMILY.
>> DESPICABLE.
WE'LL GET TO MORE ON THAT.
THIS IS THE KEY.
THERE ARE VERY KEY MOMENTS IN
THE SCHIFF SHOW.
AND THE SCHIFF SHOW, ONE MOMENT
WHEN ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES
ACTUALLY SAID, YOU KNOW, WENT
THROUGH THE ENTIRE ISSUE, NO
FACT WITNESSES.
MATT GATES DID A GREAT JOB ON
THAT TODAY ALSO.
NOT EVERY -- NOT ONE FACT
WITNESS EXCEPT AMBASSADOR
SONDLAN, WHAT DO YOU WANT?
NOTHING, NO QUID PRO QUO.
YOU FOLLOWED IT UP, WHEN DID
THEY MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENT?
AND SONDLAND -- EXPLAIN?
>> WHEN DID IT HAPPEN?
HE SAID THEY WEREN'T GOING TO
GET A CALL, A MEETING, THE
MONEY, UNLESS THERE WAS AN
ANNOUNCEMENT MADE BY THE
PRESIDENT SAYING THEY WERE GOING
TO INVESTIGATE BIDEN.
GUESS WHAT?
THEY GOT THE CALL, THE MEETING,
THE MONEY, AND THERE WAS NEVER
EVER AN ANNOUNCEMENT.
AND THE ONLY THING EVER SAID
DIRECT EVIDENCE WAS WHEN
AMBASSADOR SONDLAND ASKED THE
PRESIDENT, WHAT DID THE
PRESIDENT SAY.
I WANT NOTHING, NO QUID PRO QUO.
I WANT THIS NEW GUY, THE NEW GUY
THAT RAN ON ANTI-CORRUPTION
PLATFORM, I WANT TO DO WHAT HE
SAID BECAUSE I'M TALKING ABOUT
THE HARD EARNED TAX DOLLARS OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN OUT TO
GET THIS GUY FROM EVEN BEFORE
THE ELECTION WHEN THEY LAUNCHED
THE TRUMP-RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
IN THE SUMMER OF 2016.
>> SEAN: LAST WORD, DO WE HAVE
ANY IDEA WHERE THIS GOES?
IS JERRY NADLER GIVING YOU A
HEADS UP OF WHAT'S NEXT?
>> NO, THIS IS SAD, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TUTH BE OUTRAGED WITH THE
WASTE OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS, TIME,
WITH THE SCHIFF SHOW, THE NADLER
CIRCUS, WE HAVE NO IDEA.
I GAVE HIM AN OPPORTUNITY IN HIS
CLOSING TO SAY, WHERE ARE WE
GOING FROM HERE?
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN?
INSTEAD OF BRINGING THESE
ACADEMICS WHO DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE SHOW,
HAVE FACT WITNESSES, PEOPLE WHO
WOULD BE ABLE TO TESTIFY, THAT
IS NOT WHAT WE'VE GOT GOING ON.
SEAN, IT'S A JOKE, IT'S A
CIRCUS, IT'S OFF OF THE TRACKS
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT.
AND BY THE WAY, I'M GOING TO PUT
IN ONE MORE PLUG, ADAM SCHIFF
NEEDS TO COME OUT OF HIDING, GET
COURAGE AND BACKBONE, COME TO
THE COMMITTEE AND TESTIFY.